defender of the Fatherland day is a very
important patriotic holiday in the
Russian calendar and yesterday's concert
was really looking ahead to today uh
wishing the Armed Forces luck talking
about Russian Unity today as you say a
more somber moment where he uh laid a
wreath at the Tomb of the Unknown
Soldier to commemorate Russia's Soviet
Union's huge casualties in World War II
but remember that those casualties have
been significantly added to over the
past year thanks to Vladimir Putin's
invasion of Ukraine the last official
casualty count that the mod the ministry
of defense gave for the Russian Armed
Forces was 6 000 in September just under
6 000 and when you compare that to the
U.S estimates that perhaps as many as
200 000 Russian soldiers have been
killed or injured in this war well it
does give you something to think about
given the fact that this war has gone on
for a year and doesn't look like it's
going to end any time soon the speech
that Vladimir Putin recorded this
morning for defender of the Fatherland
day was also interesting because of what
he said about building up the
capabilities of Russia's nuclear forces
talking about how the Satan II missile
as it's called the samat missile
intercontinental ballistic missile would
now be deployed that's been in testing
for quite a long time and also that
other Hypersonic missiles that have
already also been in testing would be
delivered to the Navy and at some point
also to the Air Force and I think those
are signals to the West that Russia's
nuclear capabilities are very much up
and running and at the ready and a lot
of nuclear deterrence is about the
language that you use and not just the
Weaponry
um but when you think about these kinds
of weapons they're not necessarily the
ones that are going to be used on the
ground in Ukraine what Russia needs in
Ukraine is a lot more ammunition and
regular weapon system to supply its
armed forces and we have have seen a
very interesting spat between the head
of the Wagner group yevgeni prigojin and
the ministry of Defense over the last
few days where vigorian has been calling
out the Russian Armed Forces for not
providing his men with the ammunition
that they need and perhaps as a result
this morning he said today at 6am we
seem to have had some signatures on
papers which say that we'll get the
ammunition that we need in seeing what a
sacrifice the Wagner forces have made
around bakmut you would hope that they
do start to get ammunition or whether it
just reflects on a lack of
resources for the Armed Forces as a
whole